finally tonight this week's edition of
notable quotables I just hear boom boom
we've received no warning and no
indication in 2017 the FBI received
information I'm going to be a
professional school we've already began
to dissect these websites some of the
things that come to mind are very very
this makes no sense this is impossible
my girl my 14 year old baby you're
suffering
is our burden also I'd rather pass gun
safety legislation than win the election
in March in late July and in November in
January they clearly have work to do to
fix their their vetting system and
totally opposed to domestic violence of
any kind a great confidence in this good
man
one of the biggest spending increases in
the history of this country at a time
when we were elected to do just the
opposite frankly the United States is
under attack it's not an opening bid for
negotiations it's a best and final offer
no one is going to get everything they
want this morning week I try to
negotiate smaller ears less gray hair
struck out on that as well a
heartbreaking week in parkland Florida
and our thoughts and prayers are with
the families that have been devastated
there the president is at the hospital
tonight thanking the medical
professionals for saving lives